DIRECTOR DAVID
PETRAEUS IS HERE US
UNDERSTAND THIS ALL.FOR JOININ.
INIAN MIRY
OFFICIAL SAYS THSSIANS ARE
MAKI PREPARATIONS FOR LLED A MA.
IT SEEMS FM WHAT W
FROM WHAT GENERAL MILLEY SAI
WOODED WHICH I GUESS
UKRAINIAN ICE BA KYIWEREOR
GUERRILLACTICS.OU EXPECTING NEX?
>> IT WILL BE QUIT
LET'S REVIEW WHAT HAPPENED
REALLY
QUICKLY.
WHAT WE'VE SEEY THE
MAIN EFFORT WAND SO YOU
SAW THE COLUMN THAT CAMEOWN
AL C EREHE OTHER ONE AME OVERE,R
AND SUMY AND
RA AND
THEN TO COUNTERATTACK ANTHS WITW
ALL THESE ESE THAT.
UKRAINIANS WON THE BATTLES OF
KYIV, CHERNIHIV ANSUMY.
SO TRYING TO GET T
THAT IS THIS AREA .THIS IS WHAT
E SEPARATISTS .
YOU STILL HAVE
ON, THERE'S STI
EAS IN WCH THERE IST
HAVE T BUTE THEY
OF COMING DOWNERE.LIKE THIS ANDS
CAN SEE.TTLE SAL
WHENCIRCN, UKES THAT HAVE BEEN
FR WHICHSSENTIALLY THE
IS ALMOSRLI KIND OF
SILHES.
I'VE BEEERE.
IS IS MUCH MHERE ARE SOM
ROUBL.
BY TS WHERTHAT
BOM OF E TRAIN
STATION TOOK PLACEHASCUSSED EAR.
SO TO COME BACK TO DON DOING'RER
THEY'RE COMIOU, AGAIS
THEY'RE GOING E PUSHED I
THERE IN01HAT DOES ILL YOU , YOE
DVORNIKOV IN CHARGE OF THE
INVASION NOW NOT JUST OBVIOUSLY
THAT S
MEAN THAT IT'S GOING TO GET EVEN
WORSE, EVEN MOREL, E
MORE TARGETINGCIVILIAN
>> I FEAR THATT MAY.
I THINK WE CAN EXPECT THAT.TINGR
WE SAW, YOU E VERYIR
OPERATION TAKEN UNDER HIM
THAT TERRIBLE STRIK STATION.
SOG TO SEE THE GAE FOCUS IS THE
SOUTHEAST.
EYU KNOW, PHASE R
ICH , THE MAIN
EFFORT ONA
KYIV, THEY DIDN'T TOPPLE THE
ZELENS-RUSSIAN
FIGURE.
L
INTO THE SOUTHEAST.
WHAT THEY'D LIKE TO DO OF COURSE
IS BY 9 MAY TH'D
A SUCCESS SO THAT WHENY
CED WAR II VICTORY
UKRAHE HAD THE
THAT'S ALL THEY REALLYNG.
D
A THAT WOULD BE ALL OFHT HERUS I
LINK.
HE COULD THAT AS
SUCCESS, PRESIDENT PUTOU
SOU ACTUALLYTH W
E O
OVERALL COMMANDER. HAS BEEN INV,
NOW EVERYONE ELSE TE
ASN CHARGEINK N --YOU CAN EXPECE
FOR HAS  INNT F THE RUSSIAN
IT HASEEN VIOLATIOHE
GENEVA CONVENTION AND THE LA
OF THAT AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
OF E
AHD. WE HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING W
CAN TO P EVERYTHIN
>> GENERAL DAVS,
ING US
UNDERSTAND TER.
REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
PROPOSINE EASTER
BRING AN ETHE OOBRIN EWAE EXRTM
GH KEY PART OF WTEUK.
THEY KNOW  A .FE UNDER
REPRESSION.NT TO WARN YOU, SO
IMTO BRING YOU
ARE GRHID . Reporter: ONLY 25 Y
STATUE CAST INS
INN BREAKING FREOF
RUSSN BOAGSCRIPTION, TO THE VIC
OF COMMUNIST CRIMES.UE WAS BUILE
A FORMER SOVIET
PRISONER.
ANTHE OTHER SUCH
>> Reporter: VICE OR OF SMALL?>R
UKRAINIANIVERSITY INA FORMER P
OPPIOS IS THE PLACE WHERE THE
>> RorO TINY
CELLS ANS OF
DIFO AGAINST CMAN RIGHTS A MA A
PRISONER.
S DARED ter: IN THE 1970
DOMELISH SOVIETSNITARIINE.
TOVEN RIGHTSHAPUTIRY
ORGANIZATIONS FROM TOD>> WE WERD
DANGEROUS STATE ALS.
>> THIIS JBECAUS
DETAILED HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES
THAT WASR CRIME?
IT WASE OF OF COURSE, THET UNION
QUESTIONEDTHINWETE DENIED ATIONN
SMALL TOWN IN
KAZAKHSTAN
R UTH T THE
BRALIN.
>> MASS GS, MASS
TORTG, AWFUL INFORMATION WAR
AGAINSLOCAL POPULATION.
NOW WE SEE THE SE TEQUE IN
THE EASTER UKRAINE
IF THEN TH
WHOLE E
MI AWFUL
VER OAT
NER ONCED THE PA
IS NEVER DEAD,S NOT EVEN.
F UKRAINE THEY DON TO IMAG LIF E
ALREADY LIVED
AND HUMAN RIGHTS ACTIS
THOSE CELLS STL HERE>> TranslatA
I OF THE
SOWS
THEMSELVES AS UATION OF THE SOV
OR RATES
R A LIVING TG D.  TransUKRAINIAE
AGAINST THE IAN
AND HISTOING
ONCE AGAIN.
DCT THA
UKIAURSELF HAVE
ENHI HAVE SURVIVED
IT, HAVE BEEN STRONGH TO
BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND THE DANGER
M HAPPEN WI UUTINWIRS
ECHOS NOLYWHPUTIN YSF S WHO TRI
STALN WOO APPEASE PUTIN.
WORLD CI
SE WE BETTER
PRESERVECE, BUT FOR USS VI IN TL
AGAIN.
COMMUNIST , COMMUNIST  O
VI'S WHY I NOW SAY TO THPL